i'd love to
know if she ever does watch it if she
likes it or what she thinks of it but
she's off following her bliss with that
biker gang
the obliterators
i hope she's okay it's sam i hope
they're okay
you and i talked about before the show
had premiered how you guys were really
honoring the character of sam that she
still does exist in this world and you
guys have done such an incredible job
throughout the whole season of
mentioning her harley talking about the
fact that she does miss sam i just wish
she was here so we could do icarly again
why was that so important for you to
include in the show i really liked the
most recent episode because we mentioned
the sam character and how carly has a
card that they bought together and it
always makes her think of her friendship
with sam my best friend sam and i saved
up and bought vin diesel together when i
was in college
she's actually the one who named him
we went everywhere in that car i can
totally relate to that in real life
because i didn't want to get rid of my
first car at all the car that i got when
i was 16 i was so sentimental about it
so i definitely related to the character
in that episode and i would even drive
around when i was younger with jeanette
and we'd go through mcdonald's and do a
bunch of fun stuff so it was very kind
of meta i guess because it's a lot like
real life a couple years ago sam moved
away and i just really miss her the show
has premiered and it's so good have you
talked to jeanette since the show is
premiere and any feedback i don't think
that she has seen the the show since it
aired so i'm not sure i'm not sure if
she will or not but i'd love to
know if she ever does watch it if she
likes it or what she thinks of it
fingers crossed maybe in season two we
could maybe convince her to do a cameo
maybe the door is always open are you
thinking what i'm thinking outfit
montage i absolutely love the dynamic
between carly and harper their
friendship is like a breath of fresh air
it's so effortless what has the fan
reaction been like for you to see in
their friendship it's great i mean i
love lacie mostly i think she is
unbelievable she came into the show and
really um just brought so much life to
it and we have so much fun on set
together and in real life we're really
close so i feel like you can kind of see
that when you watch the show because we
just have so much fun together and i
love that as a producer you actually do
have power over what you do or do not
want to see in this series because
nobody knows carly better than you was
there anything that you really pushed
for in this first season that you were
excited to see actually happen it was
nice that they did a whole story line
especially it started off in the pilot
but it was a lot about carly having a
hard time standing on her own two feet i
just want to make things again
you don't need a partner to do that
yeah i don't need a partner i need sam
she's always had a co-host and she had
sam her best friend on the whole
original series and then she also had a
boyfriend that she wanted to do to
co-host a web show with and he breaks up
with her but i like that carly's really
learning that she has confidence in
herself and she can figure out how to do
it on her own and it's opening up icarly
starting it all over again in this new
way um so that was one that was
something that was important to me and i
think we covered that a good amount in
the first season